[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce set suite
l'hebdo votre émission pour rattraper
l'essentiel de l'actualité de la semaine
dans les yvelines
au sommaire ce vendredi 14 février
déclarer votre amour à l'hôpital public
c'était la thématique de cette nouvelle
journée de mobilisation du personnel
médical
nous avons suivi l'opération centre
hospitalier de versailles
andré mignot le ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner a présenté jeudi
dans les yvelines les premiers résultats
de l'audit sur l'accueil des familles
victimes de violences tant commissariats
et gendarmeries nous ferons le point sur
cette ligne en place avec notre invité
formatrice sur ces questions à la
direction départementale de la sécurité
publique des yvelines un point sur la
réforme de la première année d'études de
médecine le département qui s'équipent
aux véhicules électriques et la
sélection piste pour les championnats du
monde de berlin dévoilé nous reviendrons
sur ce qui a marqué la semaine de votre
département
ils ont commencé à se mobiliser mois de
novembre avec une grande manifestation
les soignants continuer ont profité de
cette journée du 14 février pour invités
personnels hospitaliers usagers a
déclaré leur amour à l'hôpital public
c'est une manifestation avait lieu ce
vendredi à paris au centre hospitalier
de versailles aussillon soutenait le
mouvement
un choeur de post it pour les mots
d'amour en rouge et les aspects négatifs
en noir au mois de janvier plus d'un
millier de médecins hospitaliers chefs
de service et responsable d'unité signé
une lettre menaçant de démissionner de
leurs fonctions administratives s'ils
n'étaient pas entendus depuis des
démissions ont eu lieu sur tout le
territoire français
l'objectif est de faire pression sur le
gouvernement et obtenir une négociation
autour de l'hôpital public renforcé
l'attractivité des métiers de soignants
revaloriser les salaires et rediscuter
du budget global de l'hôpital on écoute
philippe rousselot chef de service
hématologie oncologie à l'hôpital mignot
au micro de nicolas kirillovitch crois
qu'il faut qu'on soit dans une dynamique
très positive avec l'hôpital public
remplit beaucoup de missions je pense
que l'ensemble des publics et des
usagers sont très attachés ta public et
beaucoup de soignants sont également
très attaché alors à leur hôpital
cette fois le peuple lui tend le général
est à l'hôpital dans lequel il travaille
en particulier ils font c'est très
important de bien comprendre que le
mouvement de défense de l'hôpital public
s'inscrit pas contre
des établissements en fait simplement il
vit la défendre l'ensemble du service
public hospitalier de la santé
[Musique]
christophe castaner ministre de
l'intérieur s'est déplacé jeudi à la
direction départementale de la sécurité
publique à viroflay
il a présenté les premiers résultats des
audits d'accueil est prise en charge des
femmes victimes de violences sexuelles
et sexistes reportage de mathilde et
demi
christophe castaner ministre de
l'intérieur découvrait hier les
résultats de la campagne d'évaluation
qui a été menée de septembre à décembre
2019 sur un panel de sites sans victimes
de violences sexuelles et sexistes pour
près de 90% des victimes
il n'y a pas de difficultés pour
enregistrer une plainte déjà le premier
grand combat c'est celui de la
libération de la parole
nous avons aujourd'hui une augmentation
des plaintes sur les violences
intrafamiliales et c'est une bonne
nouvelle certains jouent à commenter ces
statistiques en disant voyez la
situation va mal non une chose est sûre
c'est que je ne considérerai jamais
qu'une femme qui franchit la porte d'un
commissariat ou une gendarmerie pour
porter plainte c'est un problème
statistiques c'est un problème de
sécurité de sûreté que nous devons
garantir et chaque femme qui
franchissait plus porte là doit être
protégé mieux encore selon les audits
réalisés dans les commissariats et
brigades de gendarmerie plus de 75% des
victimes trouvent que la confidentialité
des locaux est satisfaisante pour la
gendarmerie l'objectif est qu une femme
victime de violences déposent plainte
dans un premier temps aux l'isolent
parce que généralement elles sont assez
gêné la situation s'est déjà très
compliqué pour elle de passer la porte
de la gendarmerie
donc si en plus elle devait être dans un
milieu ouvert ou reçoit où il ya des
va-et-vient que ce soit des gendarmes
deux personnes civiles ça peut être
assez gênant pour elles mêmes seront
fermés au contraire au lieu de nous
donner toutes les informations
les tout garder pour elle et se
renfermer sur elle même en disant mais
peut-être qu'en fait c'était pas la
bonne solution je n'aurais pas dû venir
et regretter son son acte alors qu'en
fait c'est un très grand pas qu'elles
ont kalfon et nous
on lit on les isole et ensuite on prend
au cas par cas on a beau être formées
chaque victime est différente
suite à la présentation du travail des
enquêteurs le ministre de l'intérieur
tire un bilan positif n'est pas encore
pleinement satisfaisant je veux aussi
d'ailleurs que nous affirmions encore le
questionnaire pour une évaluation plus
rigoureuse plus précise encore de
l'accueil dans nos commissariats et dans
nos gendarmerie christophe castaner
s'est rendu par la suite à l'hôpital
mignot pour signer une convention dans
les établissements de santé en vue
d'améliorer la prise en charge des
plaintes des victimes de violences
conjugales
quant à l'audit il se poursuivra durant
l'année 2020
lauriane paturel vous êtes avec nous
bonjour nous bonjour alors vous êtes
brigadier de police et formatrice à la
direction départementale de sécurité
publique des yvelines
enfin on l'a vu dans le reportage de
bilan il est plutôt positif concernant
l'accueil des femmes violentées est ce
que c'est quelque chose que vous
constatez vous même
oui tout à fait c'est à dire que ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que de toute
façon nos collègues sont professionnels
ça c'est un fait
le sujet des violences conjugales est
très particulier ça fait plus de dix ans
sur les yvelines il ya des formations
déjà sur les violences conjugales et ça
fait plusieurs mois maintenant qu'on
s'affaire à faire des petites formations
bien précises pour que tous nos
collègues comprennent le processus des
violences conjugales et qu'il n'y ait
pas de frein aux femmes qui est aux
hommes qui pourraient être victimes de
violences conjugales à franchir la porte
d'un commissariat
qu'est ce qui se dit finalement de
formation qui est sur quoi vous accentué
les choses alors ses dernières
formations dont je vous parle qui sont
finalement les plus importantes parce
que on les fait déjà sur site c'est à
dire que avec macaulay dumas jean
goulard on se déplace dans tous les
commissariats des yvelines pour faire
des formations à tous nos collègues qui
sont susceptibles d'être en contact avec
des personnes victimes de violences
et elle se déroule en deux parties une
première partie sur la compréhension du
processus des violences ce qui se passe
au niveau physiologique psychologique
neurologiques comprend le phénomène de
l'emprise qui est vraiment pas toujours
évident à comprendre parce
qu'effectivement les victimes se
retrouvent face à nous avec des
comportements qu'on pourrait dire entre
guillemets inadaptée parce que la
personne classique va attendre quelqu'un
peut-être des pleurer de tristes or il
ya parfois des état de sidération des
choses qui font que c'est pas facile de
sanaa
grâce à ces formations déjà tous nos
collègues vont comprendre ce processus
et puis la deuxième partie va consister
à faire des voix la déteste et puis
surtout des petites leur donner des clés
sur l'accueil
parce que bon on sait les choses à faire
à dire nos collègues et ils ont fait une
école de police
ils sont sur le terrain tous les jours y
connaissent en revanche sur le thème
bien précis des violences conjugales
parfois il ya des choses à ne pas dire
ou à ne pas faire et c'est là dessus
qu'on a insisté et qu'on va leur donner
ses clés or le ministre disait
finalement il ya une augmentation du
nombre de plaintes et voient ça comme
quelque chose de positif c'est que la
libération la parole se fait et elle se
fait au sein des commissariats et des
postes de police
oui tout à fait c'est ça veut pas n'est
certes pas nécessairement dire que le
nombre de victimes augmente
effectivement comme l'a dit notre
ministre ça veut dire que la parole se
libère
pendant très longtemps les femmes
victimes de violences n'ont pas osé
parler parce que c'était un tabou elles
ont peur des fois de se rendre ne serait
ce que dans les associations et elle
avait encore plus peur de se rendre dans
les commissariats
grâce à ces formations grâce à la
formation bien précise du personnel sur
ces sujets c'est quelque chose qui
arrive de moins en moins et bien sûr le
but vous l'avez compris c'est
l'excellence en la matière et nous on
veut que 100 % des femmes qui pourraient
ou des hommes je le redis qui pourraient
potentiellement être victimes de
violence conjugale n'est pas en tout cas
le tabou où la crainte de franchir une
porte du commissariat on va les aider
d'une manière comme d'une autre on les
orientera on prendra leur plainte on
prendra leur déclaration il n'y a aucun
souci
le but c'est que voilà 100 % des
personnes victimes
en tout cas franchissent la porte du
commissariat sans se poser de questions
alors ce renforcement de la formation
des professionnels en contact avec les
victimes c'était justement l'une des
propositions ressorti lors du grenelle
des violences conjugales qui s'est tenue
en fin d'année 2010 9
parmi les mesures fortes on retrouve
également la possibilité de porter
plainte à l'hôpital et justement
christophe castaner après son passage à
viroflay s'est rendu aux chaînés pour
signer une convention au centre
hospitalier de versailles permettant
d'améliorer cette prise de plainte en
milieu hospitalier
c'est un vrai partenariat entre forces
de sécurité et les acteurs de la santé
comme il l'a expliqué oui tout à fait en
fait c'est vrai que mon avec le
groupement hospitalier sud territoire et
là dessus il ya cette convention qui a
été signée
c'est à dire que dans les grandes lignes
une personne victime de violence qui
viendrait à l'hôpital pour des soins et
qui souhaiterait déposer plainte d'une
part et qui ne serait pas en
possibilités physiques de se déplacer
d'une part la police nationale la
gendarmerie nationale sur les yvelines
s'engage à ce qu'un enquêteurs puissent
se déplacer en civil rapidement à
l'hôpital pour recevoir cette plainte
d'autre part que l'hôpital lui s'engage
à nous fournir un une salle descente
confidentiel pour qu'on puisse
effectivement pour la plaine dans les
meilleures conditions
de part et d'autre que le personnel
hospitalier soit formé informations
continues sur le problème des violences
conjugales
de notre côté évidemment que le
personnel de gendarmerie police
nationale continue les formations sur ce
sujet et puis ils auront aussi un outil
une grille qui leur permettra de leur
donner la marche à suivre
est ce qu'il faut téléphoner au 17 est
ce qu'il faut faire un certificat
médical est ce qu'il faut faire un
recueil et c'est d'ailleurs le
certificat médical aussi qui devra être
établi à chaque fois et puis nous de
notre côté suite au grenelle il y avait
eu aussi l'évaluation de la grille
d'évaluation justement qui peut
permettre aux enquêteurs d'avoir
une bonne visibilité sur la situation de
la personne est ce qu'elle est gravement
en danger ou pas les mesures à prendre
rapidement vous l'avais dit il ya des
formations qui existent déjà depuis dix
ans finalement autres outils qui
existent dans les yvelines cette
plateforme pour signaler ces violences
au commissariat de guyancourt c'est
quelque chose dont vous parlez leur de
l'information s'en saisissent et bien
sûr donc évidemment nos collègues en
principe sont au courant de l'existence
de cette plateforme néanmoins les jeunes
un ak nan c'est un outil qui fonctionne
très très bien voilà on y accède entre
autres par le site service public.fr il
ya un onglet tout en bas et donc dans
ces formations les formations se déplace
dans les commissariats on rappelle à nos
collègues qu effectivement dans le cas
où une personne que ce soit sur le
terrain ou au commissariat qui auraient
du mal à se livrer tout de suite elle
peut grâce à cette plateforme se livrer
en tchat
elle sera directement en contact avec un
enquêteur qui lui sera accompagné aussi
d'une psychologue et ça peut permettre
de débloquer des situations parce
qu'aussi il faut savoir qu'il ya des
personnes qui ne souhaitent pas toujours
déposer plainte et que le fait déjà d'en
parler parce que ça peut être des choses
prescrites et ses draps sont déjà le
libérateur pour elle alors il ya aussi
des associations et des collectifs qui
se mobilisent bien sûr pour lutter
contre les violences sexistes et
sexuelles c'est le cas notamment de nous
toute façon 18 dont les militants ont
distribué des violentes au maître dans
les yvelines ce week-end et nous y
étions
bonjour madame a progressé à des
questionnaires sur les violences faites
aux femmes
ce questionnaire c'est un violent tôt m
un outil de mesure des violences
psychologiques et physiques au sein du
couple
cet outil permet de se situer de voir si
on est dans la zone verte ce qui est
très bien douze ans la zone orange ou là
il faut commencer à réagir et la zone
rouge où là il faut vraiment pas retirer
et se faire aider
ça peut être un outil qui qui amorce de
dialogue
al'approche de la saint valentin le
collectif nous tout soixante dix huit
s'est dit que cette fête des coupes
seraient meilleurs sans violence ils
sont 30 à distribuer 3000 violente au
maître tout le week end dans six
communes des yvelines dans notre but est
plutôt d'attirer l'attention et des
veillées et puis aussi de permettre à
certaines personnes qui n'osent pas
aborder les sujets peut-être d'ouvrir la
discussion ou de les aider à prendre
conscience des climats des violences
qu'elles peuvent vivre un outil pour une
prise de conscience oui ça fait rien je
trouve que c'est bien ça quand même ça
permet quand même aux gens de dévaluer
en fait parce qu'on peut toujours se
dire voilà c'est non il va il va changer
si tu lorsqu'on se dit et puis en fait
ben non il s'enflammait et effectivement
ça permet de mettre des mots sur des
actions et sur des ressentis le
collectif nous tout des yvelines
envisage déjà de recommencer
l'expérience pour poursuivre la
sensibilisation prochaines distributions
prévues devant l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines à destination
des étudiants depuis le 1er janvier 2020
des femmes ont été tuées par leur
conjoint ou ex conjoint dont une dans
les yvelines
selon le collectif alors lion automate
pour les associations vous vous avez
aussi votre propre questionnaire vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure oui tout à
fait donc effectivement j'ai
connaissance nous avons connaissance de
ce violent tôt m qui est un très bon
outil 1
comme je vous disais on travaille
également un partenariat avec des
associations notamment sur les yvelines
et suite au grenelle effectivement il
était prévu l'élaboration d'une grille
d'évaluation justement sur
la dangerosité est le cas de chaque
victime voilà c'est un outil très
pratique qui permet en quelques
questions clés de d'avoir voilà une
évaluation sur la situation de la
personne et dans quelle situation il se
trouvait ce qu'elle est en grave danger
ce qu'elle est en danger
est ce qu'elle est en situation
préoccupante et a alors pour conclure
cet entretien on a 10 75 % de
satisfaction quels sont les leviers pour
arriver à 100% alors je pense que 100%
on peut y arriver il faut que nous on
continue nos actions de formation bien
évidemment on va aussi faire des
partenariats pour former les polices
municipales on aura des voiles à des
partenariats avec les mairies avec les
partenaires sociaux si tout le monde
fait l'effort
il n'y a aucune raison qu'on n'y arrive
pas tout passera par la formation la
sensibilisation est ce qu'on s'attelle à
faire depuis des mois merci par une
pâture l2 nice en a nous a tous alors je
le rappelle vous êtes vous régaler de
police en charge de la formation pour la
ddsv 78 et aussi on rappelle le numéro
des cours gratuits ouverts 24 heures sur
24 le 39 19
et nous on passe au reste de l'actualité
de la semaine
[Musique]
la réforme de la première année de
médecine anciennement appelée passait ce
sera appliqué à la rentrée prochaine
les actuels terminal qui inscrivent leur
choix sur parcours se sont directement
concernés le fr de santé de l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
organiser ses journées portes ouvertes
la semaine dernière sur fond
d'inquiétudes concernant cette réforme
cette réforme voulue pour diversifier
les profils et décloisonner les filières
de santé portera désormais deux voies
d'accès aux études de médecine vous les
voyez une licence en droit économie aux
sciences par exemple avec une option
santé de 80 heures ou un parcours santé
avec une option dans une autre
discipline
autre nouveauté l'examen comportera
désormais des oraux le numerus clausus
et lui supprimé mais le nombre de places
sera limité
le vice doyen de l'ufr ce noeud santé
était l'invité de 7,8 journal mardi
tout ce qu'il faut voir c'est que cette
réforme va amener un continuum dans les
ai tuées et contrairement ce qui était
la paces où effectivement si ça
fonctionne et si on réussissait le
concours alors tout allait bien en
passer en 2e année c'est a en revanche
pour ceux qui échouent et c'était plus
compliqué puisqu'il avait l'impression
d'avoir perdu deux ans la la la réforme
va permettre aux étudiants d'être dans
une marche en avant finalement à partir
du moment où ils réussissent leurs
examens
ils seront dans une marche en avant qui
leur permettra de passer en 1ère 2ème
année alors peut-être pas de santé mais
dans ce qui a été dit dans le reportage
effectivement dans démineurs qui vont
choisir en droit en sciences en kiné
mais qui leur permettront non plus
d'heureux de rester scotché à un niveau
juste de deux post bac mais au contraire
d'avancé de passer progressivement l1 l2
40 véhicules renault zoé ont été livrés
au conseil départemental de versailles
en provenance de l'usiné de flins sur
seine
en tout ce sont 185 voitures qui seront
mises à disposition un investissement de
4 millions et demi d'euros pour
renouveler la flotte de la collectivité
et participer ainsi à la transition
écologique du département une nouvelle
commande de 200 autres véhicules est
prévue pour l'année 2000 21 les propos
recueillis par mathilde de 2000 et
jacques brun je crois profondément
ont nécessité la transition énergétique
je crois profondément à la nécessité
qu'il y a que chaque collectivité à son
échelle essaye d'être un bon élève et
que ce sont des petites gouttes de sang
voiture c'est vrai qu'à l'échelle des
yvelines où il ya plusieurs centaines de
milliers de voitures qui sont la
propriété des habitants ça paraît être
une toute petite goutte mais je pense
que c'est un premier exemple c'est un
calcul je pense réfléchi faut pas
oublier que la consommation carburant
donc du coup sera à zéro pendant pas
nous montrent pas mal d'années je pense
qu'ils vont garder les véhicules assez
longtemps donc le retour sur
investissement se rassurera net et clair
le 14 février vous le savez c'est la
saint valentin vous avez peut-être
réserver une table chandelles ou
préparer votre soirée en intimité et
bien que vous soyez en couple ou
célibataire la rédaction de tv 78 tard
et a déniché pour vous des idées de
sorties originales
un reportage à visionner avec amour
lorsque vous aurez choisi votre ao je
vous invite à s'approcher de lui et à
souple et a soufflé votre prénom
touché un arbre pour se reconnecter à la
nature à soi-même se débarrasser de ses
soucis isabelle partage son amour pour
la nature en ce week-end réservé aux
amoureux
elle propose une séance de civaux
thérapie à bonnel pour être bien pour
gérer son stress
on peut aller dans la nature et profiter
notamment des arbres avec les terpènes
écrit-on side et tous les bienfaits
qu'ils ont naturellement et qui nous
font du bien
une animation précédé d'un repas le
vendredi soir à l'hôtel le bar ouvert en
juin 2018
au menu volaille sauce au vin jaune à
partager nous avons tout de même créé un
menu pour cette fête là et nous allons
plus jouer sur un côté drôle je dirais
de la fête en question un côté amusant
plus que de l'apprendre de manière très
sérieuse comme elle peut l'être et
commercial à maurepas c'est une soirée
sans valentin qui est proposée petit
love room avec speed dating au programme
et un concert mené par un dj une soirée
réservée
c'est pas réservé aux amoureux on aura
un système de bracelet on donnera des
bracelets roses pour les gens qui sont
célibataires et qui veulent faire des
rencontres et pour celles qui veulent
être tranquilles on donnera d'autres
brasseries tête à tête au coeur de la
nature ou encore autour d'un verre
l'amour se vivra ce week-end avec et
sans modération et on ouvre maintenant
une page sports direction le vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
liste des sportifs retenus en équipe de
france pour les championnats du monde
sur piste de berlin a été dévoilée ce
mercredi les détails de michael et lui
d'euros et patrick châteaux dixmude une
conférence de presse à temps dieu la
sélection piste point championnats du
monde de berlin a été dévoilé ce rendez
vous organisé du 26 février au 1er mars
fera office de test à quelques mois des
jeux olympiques
on a une équipe de france qui est très
bien dans sa trajectoire par rapport à
tokyo et du coup qui va aborder ces
championnats du monde à la fois pour y
faire des résultats pour performer est
ce que c'est important est à la fois
également je pense pour prendre de
l'assurance de confiance là où il ya
besoin dans la construction vers tokyo
sur les épreuves d'endurance on
retrouvera notamment à certains bryan
coquard champion du monde en 2015 sur la
piste du vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines
je me sens plutôt bien un vrai dire j'ai
créé repris l'entraînement veut dire le
1er décembre
et voilà ces derniers entraînements sur
piste sont plutôt plutôt encourageant je
participerai à la course aux points au
championnat du monde
je suis champion d'europe en titre bien
évidemment j'ai envie d envie de bien
faire du côté du sprint pas de surprise
on retrouve les désormais
incontournables grégory baugé sébastien
vigion ou encore mathilde de gros mais
l'une des stars de cette équipe de
france sera quant à la fargue évinois
licencié au vc le sky avait remporté
l'or sur le kilomètre et large en
vitesse par équipes sur les derniers
mondiaux en 2019
c'est toujours un moment important cette
sélection est et ce champion du monde
tous les ans qui revient mais qui fait
toujours plaisir à enfin de porter porté
les couleurs des équipes de france au
plus haut niveau donc je l'attendais je
l'espérais et je suis content de faire
partie du collectif la fédération
française n'a pas voulu annoncer
d'objectif chiffré de médailles sur les
championnats du monde les premières
épreuves sont programmées le mercredi 26
février à partir de 13 heures de la
piste à la route dans moins d'un mois le
paris-nice et lancera une nouvelle fois
dans les yvelines depuis 2010 à esso et
le département ont lié un partenariat
autour de l'événement retour sur cette
première édition c'est notre rubrique ça
s'est passé
[Musique]
côté supporteurs ce prologue du paris
nice c'est la bonne occasion de revoir
les idoles de demander un autographe
michel par exemple suivi la carrière du
directeur sportif de l'équipe de la
française des jeux
marc madiot depuis 27 ans en suivant
tous les coureurs de la française des
jeux a bien contenu sur une course
on encourage toute l'équipe six à neuf
coureurs on applaudit les neuf coureurs
donc en équipe et drapeaux supporters
vêtements supporters voilà on a la
panoplie du parfait supporter et même de
petits nounours sur la voiture quand on
est passionné de cycle et c'est assez
formidable des dettes au contact de les
voir passer dans à côté de nous et tout
c'est dans ces tops chez bref je suis
pas comment dire mais bon c'est ça ça ça
fait quelque chose
côté coureurs l'ambiance est plus
concentré après une reconnaissance du
parcours le dimanche matin à la
mi-journée l'heure était aux
échauffements pour les premiers partants
du prologue ça c'est compliqué il ya une
bosse de départ qu'un petit secteur pavé
bon
les positions général quand même se joue
aussi un petit peu au début sur certains
paris nice n'y a pas vraiment de les
gros leaders les dix premiers n'y a pas
forcément de d'écart quand il ya des
arrivées au sommet donc c'est important
dans tout le monde après cette étape
hier encore du chemin à faire
donc bon c'est un maximum aujourd'hui
mais on verra aussi les prochains jours
il ya des choses à faire c'est le
néerlandais lars boom de l'équipe
rabobank qui a remporté ce
contre-la-montre de 8 km autour de
montfort l'amaury en dix minutes 56
secondes
[Musique]
et de deux roues à 4 lundi michaël et
demi d'euros recevait dans le 7-8 sport
un habitué du dakar
les viennois originaire de montesson
jean pierre garcin a bouclé son 16e
rallye raid comme copilote aux côtés de
christian lavieille au bord de leur
toyota ils ont terminé à la 28e place
cette épreuve disputée en arabie
saoudite parce que le rallye raid c'est
un peu une drogue quoi une fois qu'on ya
goûté on a du mal à s'en passer
soit ça plaît pas et puis dans ce cas là
où le fait qu'une fois messi 51e d'art
oui moi je j'ai l'impression d'être
tombé dedans quoi et non c'est vraiment
une passion c'est ya le voyage et à la
découverte des gens on rencontre
beaucoup de monde c'est beaucoup un
travail d'équipé parce que nous devons
faire il y en a qui conduit en afrique
au pilote mais à côté de ça et des
mécaniciens soir il ya manager pour
s'occuper tout ça non ça représente un
vrai travail d'équipé
donc c'est très sympa il souffle cette
année ses 100 bougies alors pour fêter
le centième anniversaire du grenier à
sel de trappes grégory canale et patrick
jacques de dixmude se sont replongés
dans son histoire
il s'est appelé au cours de son
existence la grange de doueir puis le
normandie avant de devenir le grenier à
sel à la fin des années 1970
l'activité cinématographique de ce lieu
emblématique de trappes et démarre après
la première guerre mondiale mais son
histoire remonte à bien plus loin
les prémices de ce bâtiment le plus
vieux de la ville sont visibles à la fin
du moyen-âge le grenier est alors un
dépôt de celles collectées par un impôt
la gabelle ce bâtiment là participé à la
à la gabelle donc à la à l'impôt sur le
sel est là la grandeur de cette bâtisse
nous laissons entendre que c'était un
lieu de stockage mais aussi un lieu de
vente
le site devient ensuite au xvième siècle
une poste aux chevaux un service de
relais pour le transport des voyageurs
et leurs bagages
l'histoire du grenier à sel est en fait
liée à celle de l'étoile d'or l'auberge
attenante
en 1919 le propriétaire du lieu demande
à la mairie l'autorisation de créer une
activité cinéma fixe à une époque où les
projections sont plutôt itinérante
les premières séances ont lieu dès 1920
la grosse activité cinéma démarre
officiellement avec
en 1945 à la sortie de la guerre où le
cinéma ou la grange devient le normandie
le cinéma le normandie et le normandie
s'arrête
en 1975 puis 6 puis le bâtiment est
repris par la ville
restauration en 1979 qui laisse
apparaître les pierres meulières du
bâtiment encore visibles aujourd'hui un
lieu avant tout d'innovation
technologique le cinéma inaugure en 1964
un écran révolutionnaire le deuxième du
type installé dans le monde l'heracles
orama c'était un écran courbes avec des
lamelles en métal qui permettait d'avoir
avec un certain objectif qui permettait
d'avoir une impression de profondeur
donc on pouvait projeter n'importe quel
film du commerce et avoir une impression
de profondeur s'était pas le relief
encore mais c'était déjà une grande
avancée technologique en 2012 le grenier
à sel s'équipe d'un projecteur 4k l'une
des premières salles à se convertir à
l'ultra haute définition elle malgré son
grand âge le cinéma de trappes n'a cessé
de se renouveler un oeil toujours tourné
vers l'avenir
on arrive à la fin de cette édition
merci de nous avoir suivi on se quitte
avec des images du château de maison à
maison laffitte qui met en ce moment le
style rococo à l'honneur vous pouvez
retrouver toutes les informations sur
l'exposition et les ateliers dans le 7-8
loisirs du 13 février retour de votre
actualité locale dès lundi bon week-end
sur tv 78
[Musique]